now according to state television uh the
republic of congo president dennis sasso
has
been re-elected extending his 36 years
in power this vote marred by concerns
over transparency with some candidates
boycotting the polls or
being jailed malcolm webb's in brazil
following
developments for us uh what are the
numbers look like malcolm
well according to the electoral
commission it's a sweeping victory for
jenny sasso and greta with more than 88
percent of the vote
i've just spoken to uh officials from
the leading opposition party who've
already said that this result
is incorrect their candidate breeze
parfait uh kolilas
died on late monday late sunday or early
monday reportedly from
kovid so one of the things they saying
that should have been invoked is a
constitutional requirement
if a candidate dies to cancel the
election and have a rerun they're saying
that their demand for
that constitutional uh requirement to be
applied was ignored and the results went
ahead
uh anyway as you said uh some opposition
candidates were in jail two were
sentenced to
40 years forced labour accused of trying
to
launch an armed insurrection that was
after they challenged the results of the
last election
a lot of rights activists say that
there's no freedom of speech and there
was no chance of having any
democratic process in the first place
okay thanks malcolm for the update
malcolm webb following the elections
in republic of congo